have you ever wondered what movies were
filling seats at the movie theater
around the time of your birth well if
you were born in 1970 or later we've got
the answer to which film brought in the
biggest crowds as you were making your
big entrance
here are the biggest hits at the
American box office released each and
every year from 1970 to 2016 1970 love
story the aptly titled love story is
based on a popular novel by Erich Segal
and stars Ryan O'Neal and Ali McGraw as
the movie central couple this tale of
love and loss was the biggest hit of
1970 with a box office haul of 106.3
million dollars 1971 the French
Connection William Friedkin's cop
thriller the French Connection has often
been imitated but never replicated Gene
Hackman won an Oscar for his role the
movie was named Best Picture and
audiences couldn't get enough it made
more than any other 1971 movie earning
fifty 1.7 million dollars
1972 The Godfather Francis Ford Coppola
's The Godfather is regarded as one of
the most superb films of all time film
legend Marlon Brando is captivating and
it made stars out of cast members like
Al Pacino and Diane Keaton fans lined up
around the block to see the three-hour
film again and again which made it the
most popular film of 1972 that's a
terrific story 1973 The Exorcist based
on William Peter Blatty 'he's creepy
book The Exorcist is about a girl who
gets possessed by a demon named Pazuzu
audiences wanted to be terrified in 1973
and this film did it so well that it
topped the annual box-office chart 1974
Blazing Saddles Mel Brooks's parody of
old westerns and cowboy movies is a
brutally funny satire focusing on themes
of prejudice and racism and it breaks
the fourth wall when the big
confrontation spills out into a
present-day studio lot Blazing Saddles
offered something for everyone which is
why it was the biggest theatrical draw
of 1974-1975
jaws it's rare for a horror movie to
grab a Best Picture nomination at the
Oscars but jaws did just that thanks to
memorable performances from Richard
Dreyfuss Robert Shaw and Roy Scheider
all under the watchful eye of young
director Steven Spielberg jaws became
not only the most popular movie of 1975
but the highest-grossing movie ever a
title had held for just a couple of
years 1976 rocky at a time when
Sylvester Stallone was nearly broke and
unable to make it as an actor he chose
to write the classic underdog film rocky
for himself the gamble paid off
rocky won best picture at the Academy
Awards made Stallone into a bona fide
movie star and was the top grossing
movie of 1976 earning 117 point two
million dollars 1977 Star Wars the space
opera said a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away has thrilled an enchanted
audiences for 40 years now underscored
by the music of John Williams and
featuring performances by Mark Hamill
Harrison Ford Carrie Fisher and James
Earl Jones Star Wars was a nearly
perfect film the franchise starter raked
in 460 point nine million dollars at the
box office and after its initial run at
top jaws to become the highest earning
movie ever
1978 grease the charismatic John
Travolta and charming Australian singer
Olivia newton-john were at the front and
center of Greece based on the smash hit
Broadway musical right in the middle of
a 50s revival the musical demolished its
competition with a take of 188 point
seven million dollars Oh a good news
really travels fast
1979 Kramer vs Kramer Dustin Hoffman and
Meryl Streep both won Oscars for their
roles in the powerful domestic drama
Kramer vs Kramer the film was so
provocative that it enjoyed must-sees
status making it the top theatrical draw
of 1979 1980 The Empire Strikes Back the
sequel to the most game-changing beloved
and cash-generating movie ever was
virtually assured success at the box
office after throwing in an epic battle
between Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker
in which spoiler alert Luke finds out
darth vader is his dad the Empire
Strikes Back easily won the 1980 box
office with a haul of 290 point four
million dollars 1981 Raiders of the Lost
Ark Raiders of the Lost Ark was intended
to be a tribute to the Saturday
afternoon matinee serials that George
Lucas and Steven Spielberg grew up
watching but it leaves those films in
the dust riding on the confident
shoulders of Harrison Ford this wildly
imaginative thrill ride was the
highest-grossing film released in 1981
earning an impressive 248 point 1
million dollars 1982 he
see the extraterrestrial it's impossible
not to burst into tears of joy during
et's climax when the Reese's Pieces
loving alien uses his powers to launch
the bikes of Elliot and his pals into
the air he appealed to just about
everyone and it brought in a staggering
435 point 1 million dollars 1983 Return
of the Jedi the Star Wars trilogy a
series so popular that it's commonly
referred to as just the trilogy wrapped
up spectacularly with Return of the Jedi
and just like its predecessors Jedi was
the biggest blockbuster of the year of
its release its total box office take
300 nine point three million dollars
1984 ghostbusters some of the biggest
comedy icons of the decade came together
in a very big way in 1984 to fight
ghosts and other supernatural beings
menacing New York City this makes a
broad comedy ghost and Bill Murray Bean
Bill Murray made Ghostbusters a hit
raking in 240 2.2 million dollars like
the torch room 1985 back to the future a
seemingly impossible blend of comedy
sci-fi nostalgia and awkwardness the
Michael J Fox Christopher Lloyd classic
Back to the Future was a smash topping
all other 1985 movies with a 210 point 6
million dollar haul 1986 Top Gun in 1986
Americans were keenly interested in
taking a highway to the dangerzone so
interested that they shelled out one
hundred seventy nine point eight million
dollars at the box office in what's
probably his most famous role Tom Cruise
played the justifiably cocky lead
character of Top Gun your dad's favorite
movie to this day
1987 three men and a baby Tom Selleck
Ted Danson and Steve Guttenberg play a
trio of bachelors whose party down
lifestyle is rocked by the arrival of a
baby on their doorstep in the low-key
comedy three men and a baby
the surprising 1987 champion cruise to a
box office haul of 167 point seven
million dollars 1988 Rain Man it's not
often that the highest-grossing movie of
the year also wins the Academy Award
for Best Picture Rain Man starring Tom
Cruise and Dustin Hoffman is one of the
few to pull it off
bridging commercial appeal with artistic
games and scoring a whopping 172 point
eight million dollars 1989 Batman
moviegoers had never seen a comic book
film quite as big or as bald as Batman
which one 1989 by earning two hundred
fifty 1.1 million dollars directed by
Tim Burton Batman starred the unlikely
choice of Michael Keaton in the title
role although Jack Nicholson's Clown
Prince of Crime stole the entire movie
1990 home alone
you wouldn't think the year's biggest
hit would be a christmas movie starring
child actor Macaulay Culkin as an
abandoned child violently fending off
burglars but the funny fast-moving John
Hughes script made it a classic that's
worth revisiting every holiday season
still the highest-grossing Christmas
movie of all time
home alone gathered two hundred eighty
five point seven million dollars enough
to make it the number-one movie of 1990
1991 Beauty and the Beast as the lyrics
of the title song note Beauty and the
Beast is a tale as old as time but it
hadn't ever been presented as
beautifully as Disney's 1991 animated
film the delightful and emotional
musical became the first animated movie
ever nominated for Best Picture and
while it didn't win it did wind up the
highest-grossing movie to be released in
1991 1992 Aladdin the late 80s Early 90s
Disney Animation Renaissance just might
have peaked with Aladdin the beautifully
animated adaptation filled with
memorable songs fantastic characters and
a show-stopping performance from Robin
Williams as the genie Aladdin was the
biggest hit of 1992 bringing in two
hundred seventeen point three million
dollars 1993 Jurassic Park Steven
Spielberg thought it would be a good
idea to make a movie about a dinosaur
theme park based on a bestseller by
Michael Crichton using realistically
rendered dinosaurs he was right of
course and let's be honest it would have
been a shock if Jurassic Park didn't
become the highest-grossing movie of the
year
the 1993 dynaflux cook in 400 2.4
million dollars
1994 The Lion King a magnificently
animated retelling of Hamlet The Lion
King is a beautiful and emotional film
underscored by original music by Elton
John the hit musical was the third
Disney animated feature in a row to top
the annual box office earning 422
million dollars 1995 Toy Story as the
first all CGI cartoon feature Pixar's
Toy Story attracted viewers who wanted
to check out the next generation of
animation but what really brought in the
190 1.7 million dollars its premise that
toys come alive when humans aren't
around and its resonant themes of
friendship and acceptance 1996
Independence Day who wouldn't want to
see a bunch of Americans from different
walks of life team up to defeat evil
hordes of alien invaders also the aliens
blew up the White House and other
landmarks which was pretty awesome and
realistic looking in 1996 Independence
Day led by Will Smith took in a whopping
300 6.1 million dollars 1997 Titanic at
the time James Cameron's historical
romance drama set aboard the doomed
ocean liner was the most expensive movie
ever made
he'd won 11 Academy Awards turned
Leonardo DiCaprio into a household name
and became the first movie to earn six
hundred million dollars at the domestic
box office that made Titanic not only
the highest-grossing movie released in
1997 with the highest-grossing movie
ever to that point 1998 Saving Private
Ryan Steven Spielberg's gut-wrenching
world war two epic Saving Private Ryan
starring Tom Hanks was more emotionally
and physically real than any other war
film people had seen and it brought in
216 point five million dollars 1999 Star
Wars Episode one The Phantom Menace the
first of three Star Wars prequels The
Phantom Menace was probably the most
anticipated movie of all time when it
finally played two packed houses in May
1999 many were vocally disappointed a
lot of people may not have liked it but
just about everybody saw it and it
pulled in a whopping four hundred
seventy four point five million dollars
and the rest movies have gotten bigger
and flashier ever since the new
millennium hit so one can only imagine
what the future of cinema holds from How
the Grinch Stole Christmas to Avatar to
road one here
all the rest of the biggest box-office
hits from 2000 to 2016
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]